when a filmmaker gets into a festival
what should they know about hiring a
publicist
how much should they expect to pay do
they need a publicist
i think it all depends really i mean if
you're going to sundance or
south by southwest or tribeca like one
of the sort of big ones i would suggest
you do need a publicist to to make the
most out of this
opportunity you have because basically
to have your film
uh premiere at one of those top tier
festivals
you're gonna get exposed to a huge
amount of people and it's really a great
chance to publicize your film and and
give it a good launch and
as i wrote recently in my blog like i
feel now very clear
if you're making a movie like obsolidia
that is that doesn't have stars that is
a little quirky a little odd
your absolute best bet is to
self-distribute it there's absolutely no
reason to sort of go looking for a
distributor because you're probably not
going to find one and if you do
you're not going to make any money out
of it and worse than that your movie is
not going to get seen
like i really feel that you know because
uh they're not going to put the work
that needs to be done to get an audience
for that film
so i i mean i absolutely do feel if
you're going to one of the top tier
festivals one i would be planning a
self-distribution and two i think
in absolutely essential to that is
having a pr person
um what you pay for them gosh that's
like saying
what do you pay for you know how long is
a piece of rope or something
um you know you're you're gonna
figure it out you're gonna talk to a
bunch of different people and
and see and and figure it out i don't
think it's possible to
sort of say i mean if sundance is gonna
be a lot more expensive probably than if
you're dealing with somebody
at the la film festival you know because
if they're in la they're here already
and they don't have to travel to
sundance
if someone's going to go to sundance to
publicize your movie there's costs you
know
i don't think you're going to pay
someone less than five thousand dollars
to be your pr person at sundance
um you know i think that would be the
minimum that you're
looking at so it's a lot of money and
you want to make sure though that it's
for a good purpose
if you're going to i think if you're
premiering one of you know like a
smaller festival regional festival or
something
do you need a pr person i would still i
mean i would still say if you can
get someone involved it's probably not a
it's not a bad idea
because again it's just your chance to
really reach uh
reach your audience to launch your movie
you know uh
and to connect yourself with an audience
now of course ideally
i think in this like right now um
you'll have started doing that earlier
i.e
creating an audience for your movie you
don't wait until you're going to the
festival to try and get an audience for
your movie you'll
ideally have started that when you
started making a movie yeah you know and
through social media and i think there
is so much that you can do on your own
and it's absolutely conceivable that you
never deal with a pr person if you've
done that effectively
you know it had made perhaps one person
in your team like everyone's talking the
big
buzzword producer of marketing and
distribution so if you have a pmd on
your team which
i think is advisable you know then you
probably don't need a public you know
you might not need a publicist
i think there's certain we've talked
about recently i think there's certain
things though that they can still do
yeah which you can functionally you
reaching out to local radio stations
newspapers et cetera you know that they
already have connections to that they
can like access quickly
also as well it validates you as a
filmmaker as a producer as a director
as a you know it validates you also as
well to have a go-to person
who is quote-unquote the publicist and
they
make those calls for you and when they
call they're already validating you
to said radio station b or said local tv
station c
or any of those those outlets and so
they've
validated you before you've even gotten
there and so
when you get there now the people who
are going to interview you they know
hey this person's already validated
because their publicist
made the call and so by the mere fact
that you've got a publicist
then you must be somebody right and
therefore
what you're hocking what you're selling
has value
and so therefore they you know the one
feeds the other and
you know you you negotiate those prices
as and how you you know get into
conversations with
with the potential publicist but
they look all publicists look at you
know
people and films and ideas on a case
case-by-case basis
you know like with us we were looking we
found a woman called kim dixon who's
a great publicist she's a fabulous
human being to start with and then
therefore
she's very authentic and
she does the best she can with what
she's got
and that's all you can ask for and we
were very fortunate and
we've you know continued to have a great
relationship with her
you know tips on interviewing a
publicist like what are some things to
look for
besides the obvious do you have a gut
feeling about the person that
you would get along and that you can
trust them other than that
i think it would be like i think again
it depends like where you're going with
them and what you want from them and i
think you should be very clear about
what it is that you want you know what
is your goal
you know so i mean if i was going to
sundance with the movie now
my goal would be to sell tickets online
okay i'm just going to be like really
clear i would be like
here's what i want you know and so i
would be talking to the publishers about
that how are we going to reach
audience like actual possible audience
members to sell tickets to them
to our movie online you know that would
be my thing and i think like
you know just to like the thing to talk
to if you're interviewing publicist you
know is be clear about what is your goal
and what can they
do to help you achieve that you know
rather than just being sort of like
oh well we're just gonna you know we
just want our movie to be well known or
something you know
um so you know like find out who their
contacts are
you know and really what they can who
they'll be able to
help you get an article with and are
those people going to be actually
helpful to you
you know like is that is that the
audience that you want to be reached
you know so just i would really be clear
about what your goal is and just really
ask them
how they're going to help you achieve
that you know and and then you have to
then at a certain point you have to
trust your instincts as to whether they
can really
you know deliver on those things and
also as well
let them watch your project and see if
they're really passionate about it
i think that that is key because i know
when we met kim the thing was that she
loved obsolete and it was so obvious
that she absolutely loved it so you knew
that
for this woman like if she's calling
anyone up it's coming from the heart
you know like when she's telling other
people about your movie and you know
trying to get them to watch it and
trying to get them to
do an interview you know that she's like
genuinely so excited so excited
and i think i think that's like
absolutely everybody that you work with
that's who you want you know you want
that person who's like
who loves your movie you know who loves
this idea as much as you do or sometimes
more than you do and that's what you
need you know you need that because that
passion will take you
much further than than anything else
you